well inspired by groups of pom-pom
squads across the country a local woman
set out to do something pretty unique in
our city as heather mills reports with
fabulous las vegas flair they're still
welcoming new members and their
performance schedule is quickly filling
up in a city that dazzles at night what
better than gold pom poms and glittery
shoes to glam up the days we want to
sparkle and shine for vegas with just a
little self-admitted polishing the vegas
golden gals are celebrating their golden
years in style
[Music]
these are my magnificent seven belinda
potts started the group just a few
months ago i didn't care if they could
dance or march or whatever she just
wanted to have some fun with a purpose
that was one of my goals to get seniors
out there and moving
having fun making new friends
and entertaining people spreading the
joy and they are
showing off their cool moves at the las
vegas days parade it was fun it was a
lot of fun haven't done a parade in
50 years
but it's so much more than that to the
vegas golden gals it's part of their
journey i've got a couple cancer
survivors i've got a girl with a
pacemaker
a girl with a port i've got one with two
new knees you can't let it stop you you
have to keep living dixie williams
joined the group just two months after
receiving a pacemaker i went to my
doctor and he says well
you can't raise your arm over your head
you can't do any repetitions so she
improvises i have to um kind of count
out differently than they do
just to see these girls out here doing
this
i get teary-eyed every time but they
don't just do it for themselves we're
still trying to get more sponsors to
help us with our costumes and this and
that and once we can become nonprofit
then we'll be raising money for
alzheimer's and why alzheimer's why not
a pom-pom squad friends
survivors tomorrow's never promised
so you just have to you know grab it and
do what you can and you can't let it
slow you down and they're a hit you can
see them at the summerlin patriotic
parade on the 4th of july they've also
been asked to appear at an upcoming las
vegas lights game the aviators the
senior olympics and of course the walk
to end alzheimer's in october
heather mills live local now